hey I'm will I'm Adam nice to meet nice
hey good how are you I'm good thank you
Oh hungry starving what are you yeah and
very hungry cool great so Adam how did
you vote in that you referendum I most
definitely voted to leave I could never
leave okay I'm very pro Europe a few
myself as a European I love Europe okay
just thank like the e ye die votes
remains I believe myself as a European
as well as British and stand for
everything that you were stands for you
can love your own and love working of
Europe yeah but it's like it's like a
relationship where it's not really
working on different things okay know if
you love it let it go you're excited for
the day yeah yeah anticipation so we'll
see so what we don't show you're like
really unhappy that we left or you're
just sort of like a bit unhappy that we
left that first week I was heartbroken
yes means some melodramatic but I was
really upset of never being voted for ed
miliband to the general election yeah oh
gosh you've had a really bad it's been a
whole year so yeah more upset than that
when what's the whole thing yeah
horrible by half 10 though we're gonna
lose this and then and then it all
started coming in and I thought we might
my lovely face was it Nick Newcastle
some angling Sunderland house it wow
this is crazy more oh thank you very
much thank you beautiful
this looks almost continental it's not
British I don't think it's British you
can still like Europe without loving the
eee pad someone feels that they know
better and that their save more
important somebody else's I'd find that
very difficult to deal with listen I was
heartbroken that first week yeah well as
trees may he's been saying constantly
breaking news brexit yeah and
unfortunately we live in a democracy so
am unfortunately joke it's a joke today
haha execuse budget and i think i'll
have to happen yeah i think since break
is unleashed love hatred within the UK
not necessarily towards gay people i
think first of all it's been towards
migrants and refugees but that will
slowly trickle down to the other targets
such as gay people's the amount of hate
has been exaggerated i think that when
you look at some of the stuff that was
coming out the day after the vote people
were presupposing that these things are
going to happen and i think that when
you look it I mean I'm not saying that
nothing is happening and one incident is
one incident to many but people almost
indulging in some of the negativity door
they're indulging in it really every
time there's every time there's a story
that could be possibly seen as being
something to do a brexit people that
breaks it has caused this I hope you
people happy you've made this you've
made this hatred it suited some people
to make it bigger than I think the
evidence shades I don't think so I'll
disagree with you there and the Briggs
didn't vote itself the referendum pauses
I think it's only a matter of time
before it trickles down to LGBT
I had fallen out with friends falling
out with close family friends to who've
people who voted brings it just don't
stand it really don't get it and we've
got very little in common these days I
think one of things that has contributed
to some of the hate because there is
some hate there is a lot of people feel
that they're not allowed to talk frankly
about their views when it comes to
immigration I think most people when you
when you actually talk through it yeah
tend to be quite liberal in the end like
certain people might be more
anti-immigrant and initially but when
you ask about their friend or their
neighbor or whatever it's the same like
with gay people we might all know people
who maybe when they're older maybe they
didn't know gay people and initially
they might be like oh I'm not really
sure I agree with that yeah but as soon
as they get someone in their family or
friend or neighbor or so on on TV who
they quite like they changed their mind
and I think that because immigration has
never been discussed people have never
got beyond that initial phase no I think
it's at least something scary it's made
Britain lot darker and a scary a place
to be and I think there's a hell of a
lot of work going to go before you can
unify the country I don't think it's a
nap I think we are doing quite a lot I
don't think we're going to agree on the
fundamental question of what was the
right value god no it was quite nice I
was surprised i was expecting some
stuffy old Tory but he was very nice and
not stuffy your old but no not Sophie oh
no we agreed on a few things it was okay
the important stuff like being positive
about the future being label about
things like immigration yeah making sure
what we do enact the outcome of the vote
we agreed on and I think that's a that's
a really positive thing clearly do still
believe that remaining in the EU was the
best thing for the country and I still
clearly believe that leaving is the best
the issue we now got is it's on my side
to sort of prove that that we were right
and I
take that full both sides that we get
proved right not I hope you're right but
I will be on hand to say you told
yourself